hello frequent campers my name is
Jennifer bland I have created for you a
series of videos that will help you get
your very first job as a developer these
videos cover a process that's called the
whiteboard exercise this is an exercise
that you will experience when
interviewing for a job as a developer
it's where a company will evaluate your
skill sets and your abilities to
determine whether or not to hire you for
that opening position I've shown you
exact questions that I have been asked
in the past we interviewed for jobs so
that you can learn from what I have
picked on my experiences and be able to
use that to your benefit when you
interview for your very first job as a
developer I have a series of videos that
I've created for you these videos and
cover topics such as HTML
they cover CSS I have several videos on
JavaScript and also videos on jQuery
these will help you as you start to
interview for your very first job as a
developer if you have any questions or
if you need to reach out to me my
website is www.miamikettlebell.com
[Music]
right a function that takes a string as
parameter and returns the frequency of
each letter of the alphabet that's found
in that strength okay that might be a
question that you might be asked in a
whiteboarding exercising always when
you're doing a whiteboard exercising ask
questions to the potential employer so
that you understand exactly what they're
expecting from you and what you actually
want to bring to the table in terms of
the functionality of your functions
you're going to create so one of the
first questions that I might ask is okay
if you're given a string
what about case is case important is an
uppercase egg counted as one and a
lowercase a counted is one for the
lowercase or is that counted as two for
a since they're both A's and it doesn't
matter if it's uppercase or lowercase so
that would be one of the first questions
that I would ask so I'm just going to
show you how to handle this whether they
ask you to treat uppercase or lowercase
either the same or a separate loan
letters so let's get started and let's
start working on our function that we're
going to be creating for this potential
employer so we're going to start off
we're going to create a function and I'm
just going to call my function count and
my function very simple is called count
and it's going to have the string as the
input that they are giving me and what I
want to do is to go through and look
through every character that's in the
string and get count the number of times
that that letter appears in the string
and it returns that information out of
the function so the first thing that I
want to do is well what about case is
case important to you at all and you
need to find out if it is or not so
let's say that case isn't important on
and
per case a and a lowercase a are treated
exactly the same so what we can do is
the first thing we can do is we can take
our string and we're going to convert
our string to lowercase so that makes
everything in the string all lowercase
so anything that was previously
uppercase will now be lowercase and
therefore we can actually be able to
count what was previously in uppercase a
as alert and a lowercase a as the
exactly the same since they're now all
the same case so that's the first thing
I want to do now I need something some
type of container to hold the count of
each individual characters so one of the
things that you can use is you can use a
number you can use an array if you want
or you can use an object in this case
I'm going to exes solve this by using an
object so I need to define my object
that I'm going to use so I'm just going
to create an object so I have an empty
object right here and that's going to
have my count that's going to be
returned back out of this function so
the next thing that I need to do is look
through every single character that's
found in that string so I will need a
for loop
all right so now I have a four look this
will go through every single character
that's found in that string and what I'm
going to do is actually put that into my
object now what I can do is in order to
do a count I'm going to take advantage
of the functionality that's built into
an object in JavaScript
an object is basically a key value pair
what I'm going to use as a key is the
letter the value is the count of how
many times that letter has appeared
within that string so that's what I'm
going to be using so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to first check to see if
that character is in my object that I'm
going to be using as my placeholder so
if I'm going to check so what this will
do this will either return the the
actual character if it's in the object
right now and if not this will actually
return is undefined because it doesn't
exist in the object itself so what do I
want to do is if it doesn't exist then
what I want to do is go through and add
it to the object if it does exist in
this case this is asking does it exist
and if it does exist then I want to
increase that value and that key value
pair by 1 because it now has one more
character found in that string so in
order to do that what I can do is I come
in
and I basically take the the current
character which is it's found in this
key and I'm going to set its value to
its current value plus one so therefore
I'm going to basically increase it by
one right then I'm going to have an else
in here and this is if the if the
character doesn't currently exist in my
object placeholder so I'm going now
added in there and I'm going to set its
value to one because it's the first time
that this character exists so what I
have is I can put an object
I so now what I've done is I've gone in
and I've added that letter to my place
holder object and I've said it to value
equal to one and it will go through and
it will loop through everything that's
in there now the last requirement that
the potential employer asks me when they
ask me to write this function was to
actually go through and return the count
of each letter that's found within the
string so the last thing that I want to
do in my function is I actually want to
return my object and therefore I've gone
through and I've given them everything
that they've asked me to do so when
you're going through this is something
that you might have asked as part of a
coding challenge and this is how you
would actually go through and resolve
that that coding challenge now when you
start looking at this there are a couple
of things that you can actually do to
this to make it a little bit better make
it run a little bit clearer and so forth
that comes in there so one of the other
things that you might ask is well what
if the string has spaces in it what if
it has a period at the end of a sentence
what if it has a question mark or an
exclamation mark or numbers that are in
there what do I want to do in that case
and you you need to ask that question
and it's something that you should ask
because it tells the potential employer
that you're thinking about scenarios
that you might encounter in real-world
applications and that shows them that
you have that ability to think about
what might happen so that you can
account for it within your code so if
they come back and they ask you I only
want to worry about letters only the
letters A through Z I don't care about
numbers I don't care about punctuation
marks I don't care about anything else
like that so what we need to do is take
our
free that we've converted to uppercase
and now what we need to do is we
actually need to strip out anything
that's not a character and so we can
actually go in and change this so I'm
going to add a line in here and I'm
going to use a red X expression and a
regex expression will basically go
through it says here's my criteria
anything that doesn't match it I'm going
to basically strip it out of the string
so in my mind what I'm going to be
looking for is for anything that's not a
through Z or a through Z upper case and
if it's if it's in there I'm going to
replace it with quote quotes which
basically means it's going to strip it
out so if you had a string that was
hello Apple how are you today
and there was an exclamation mark at the
end of hello Apple and a how are you
today there was a question mark at the
end and then maybe one two three after
the question mark this would basically
pull out basically this would go through
and pull out all of the spaces the
exclamation marks the periods anything
that's not a letter and the letter is
anything a through Z so it's going to
remove that so that's one of the first
things that I can do as an improvement
to the first iteration that I did on my
function another thing that I can do is
if I look at this if else that that's in
here that's you starting to see some
repetition that you have in here that
it's basically taking this it's setting
this this key and it's either adding on
one to the current value or setting the
value to equal to one well you can
actually take that and combine that into
a single statement using a ternary off
operation so if we come in I'm going to
actually erase this if statement
and what we're going to do is we can
replace that and what we're replacing is
object so this is what I'm setting and
I'm going to either set it equal to one
or I'm going to take its current value
and increase it by one so I'm going to
set it equal to here and I'm going to do
a ternary operation where I'm going to
do I'm going to check to see if it's
currently there and if it is there if it
is true then I'm going to increment so
what the ternary operation is going to
do is I'm setting this value and what
I'm doing is I'm doing in comparison I'm
going to check to see if the current
letter is in my placeholder object if it
is then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take its current value and I'm
doing a plus plus on it which means I'm
going to increment it by 1 then if it's
not there then you have the false
statement and it's going to be setting
it equal to 1 so that we actually see
that and this information that holds for
loop all that if else that was in here
can be replaced with this one line so
that we have an in here and then this
information gets returned back to you so
that is a way of actually going through
and implementing a white boarding
exercise for doing things some of the
things that you might also see this
implementation of this function in some
other variations and some of the other
most common variations that you might
find on that is instead of returning the
the frequency of every care
that's found in the stream they might
ask you to return the character that has
the most frequent iteration in these
string itself so what you would do is
once you've got everything into your
object in here before you do the return
that what you're going to have to do is
to basically look through that object
and then check to see how many times
each each character occurs and you find
the one character that has the most
occurrences and then you actually return
just the character and the amount of
times that it actually occurs in there
so that's one thing that you would see
is a variation on two basically this
simple question that you're using in an
object another way of asking this
variation of this function is it comes
back and they might say I'm gonna give
you a code snippet you tell me if it is
correct or not and what their meaning is
they're going to give you something in
the string that comes in is going to be
like programming code kind of like this
function and what they want to do is to
check to make sure that you have an
equal number of like if you have an open
parenthesis you have a closing
parenthesis if you have a open curly
brace you have a closed curly brace open
parentheses close parentheses open
square bracket close square bracket and
make sure that they all line up evenly
on there and the way that they should
line up in here I have two sets of
brackets this one is open this one's
open this is closed and then this is
this closes the first one that's in
there so you should always have they
should always pair up along that line so
that's one of the things you can compare
and the way that you can go in and
modify this in
object is you would actually put in if
it has braces so you might have one of
your keys might be braces and in there
you put in all of the open braces that
you have curly braces and when you find
a closed curly braces
you should remove the open one from the
object itself so then when I come in
here I'm like okay I have a open curly
brace I mean open parentheses so I put
that into my object then I'll keep
breathing through my much string and
then when I get the closed curly brace I
will go to my object and if there's an
open curly brace in there I remove it
from the object and then I'll go along
the same thing here I'll put an open
curly brace in I mean open parenthesis
in then I'll immediately take it out
because I've reached the club's and if
we were following along in our object
our object would have it would have an
open parenthesis then it would have
nothing in it because now that open
parenthesis has been removed it would
have an open curly brace and that would
be the only thing currently in the
object then he would come around to this
line now our object will have two things
in it it would have this open curly
brace this open parenthesis when it sees
this it's going to remove this open
parenthesis from the object leaving
nothing but this open curly brace and as
you work your way through when you get
to the very end of your code you should
at the end of the string should have an
object that has nothing in it if there's
nothing in the object that means that
the code snippet is valid so that's one
of the things that you can do as a
variation for answering this question
so hopefully this information will help
you out the goal is to help you prepare
for your white boarding interview that
you're going to have for your software
engineering positions
and this is how you would actually go
about and answer these questions when
you're presented with that information
[Music]
previously I had gone through and just
did the exercises directly on the board
instead I'm going to convert over to my
computer and I'm actually going to walk
through a series of questions there you
might have as part of a whiteboard
exercise on HTML and CSS here are a
series of potential questions that you
might be asked as part of your
whiteboarding exercise on HTML and CSS
let's go through each of the questions
the first question is too bright a CSS
selector to select only the inner-tube
list items in the mark-up below we have
list items 4 1 2 3 a 3 B and 4 and what
they're asking is for us to get a CSS
selector that it would only access 3a
and 3b there are multiple ways that you
can go about doing this
so let's go through different ways that
you can access just 3a and 3b the first
one is to start from the class that we
have at the top then we go down to the
unordered list and then to the list item
itself and that would give us 3a and 3b
we can skip the class and just go from
the unordered list to the list item to
the unordered list and then to the list
item itself and that would give us
access to it also and then another way
of getting access to it would be to go
to the list item unordered list and then
list item and that tells us to go
directly to the children of the
unordered list and that would forgive us
three different ways that we can get
access to the inner tuned list items 3a
and 3b it's possible that you will be
asked a follow-up question on that in
that question in number two is to write
a CSS selector to select only the
first list item of the two lists items
in the mark-up above so what we want to
do is to get access to just three a and
not three B that we were doing
previously so we can go through and we
can start out with going to the
unordered list the list item the
unordered list the list item which would
have given us both and what we want to
do is select the first child which would
give us three a and that's the
difference between the first question
and the second question all right the
third question is what is the difference
between an ID and a class an ID has to
be unique it can be assigned to only one
Dom element at a time a class can be
assigned to multiple elements on the Dom
page in terms of specificity and ID will
have a higher value than a class because
it has to be unique an element can be
assigned book an ID and a class and an
element can also be assigned more than
one class that is in general terms the
difference between an ID and a class the
next question is is it possible to
change the location of an element on a
page via CSS and the answer is yes we
actually have two methods available to
us and that is position and float that
would give us the ability to look at
things on the page the one things that
you want to do is explain what is the
difference between position and float if
you're going to use them both of them
take the element out of the page flood
position requires a parent element to
have a position set to relative or
absolute in order for it to work
I float requires a parent element to
have a clear fix applied overflow:hidden
applied or to be flooded itself in order
for it to work
question number five what does the box
model refer to in CSS and the answer is
it refers to how elements size including
its borders margins and padding is
calculating question number six is there
a way to change the box model and the
answer is yes because the default for
the box model is content box what
content box does is it adds the borders
margins and padding to the set width and
height of the element to determine its
size if you use box-sizing border box
then for an element it's size will take
the size the height and width that it's
been assigned and the borders margins
and padding's will be subtracted from
that so that the element will fit
directly into the height and width
that's been specified for that
particular item number number seven what
is the difference between these three
selectors and we have three different
CSS selectors the first one div refers
to an element that has the name of div
and it's assigning of its background
color to be red the second one is dot
div this refers to an element that's
been assigned a class called div and it
sets his background to blue the last one
pound sign div refers to an ID and it's
fruit I'm setting the background on that
element
two green number eight giving this CSS
what would this HTML look like when it's
rendered and the CSS that we're given is
div span has a color of red and div
greater than span has a background of
green and what they're asking is do you
understand what this background greater
than span does compared to just doing
div span the first one div span what it
does is it refers to any span within a
div so here we have a span all work and
no play that's contained within the div
so this div span would be color red so
this text all work and no play would
have red text also we have down here a
span that's directly inside a div makes
Jack a dull boy
and that would make its color red so
this first element of this first CSS
would make all of the text in this HTML
to be color red now we have another CSS
that is div greater than span and we set
its background degree and what this does
is refer to a span that is a direct
child of a div and here we have a div a
paragraph and a span the span isn't a
great child of the dip it's a direct
child of the paragraph so this would not
apply the bottom one the span is a
direct child of the div so this
background green would apply in so makes
Jack a dull boy would be read text and
it would have a green background
[Music]
I want you to write a function that will
take a string as an input and it will
return whether or not that string is a
palindrome and if you're not familiar
with what a palindrome is a palindrome
is a word that's written in the same way
both forward as it is backwards radar
pop because when you think are a dar or
a dar it's written the same way but
fords and backwards the word hello on
the other hand is not a palindrome
so what you want to do is write a
function that determines if the string
is a palindrome once you've been given
the exercise by the potential employer
always ask questions that allows you to
show that you're I'm questioning what is
that you want to accomplish how you
going to be able to accomplish it and it
provides feedback to the potential
employers so if I was given that
question one of the first questions I
would ask would be what type of return
do you want to come out of this function
if it's a palindrome do you want me just
to give you the string back it will give
you a empty string if it's not a
palindrome or do you want me to return a
boolean that would be true or false
based on whether not the word that I've
been given as a palindrome so that would
be one of the first questions that I
would ask and most likely the answer
they would be given is that they want
the function to return true or false as
to whether or not the screen is a
palindrome so now that I've got some
basic information I can start working on
my function so what I do is I'll come
over here and I'm just going to say I'm
going to create a function I'm going to
call my function palindrome and it's
going to take in one parameter which is
a string so now what I have is the
beginning of what I'm going to show the
potential employment in terms of my
coding skills for solving this this
function now there are multiple ways
that you can go about solving this
function and one of the most common ways
that I've seen people try to solve it is
they will take
for loop and they will look through each
character in the string and they will
compare the that first character to the
last character in the string and if
they're the same that continue on then
they compared the next character from
the front and from the back and they
will see are they the same and then they
will keep doing it until they meet at
the middle and if they meet at that
point in every character matches then
you know that you have a palindrome
that's one way of doing it but I think
one of the things that that they're
really wanting to accomplish and that
actually mean that interview question is
how well do you know the native data
types in JavaScript
well a string is a data type one of the
native data types that are in JavaScript
another data type that you have is an
object they strained the native data
type on string does not have a method to
do a reverse of the string but the array
which is a type of an object in
JavaScript does have a built in method
called reverse that you can use to
reverse things well you're thinking well
I'm asked to reverse a string not an
array but one of the things that you can
do is show that you have knowledge of
all the primitive data types within
JavaScript and also how you can move
between them to be able to accomplish
what you want in this function so if you
want to use that built-in reverse and
not have to rewrite everything by doing
a for loop I can use what's given to me
natively within JavaScript on an array
and use that reverse function so now I
need to figure out how I can get my
string and convert it into an array well
the string method natively has a method
on it that's called split a split will
actually convert a string into an array
so this is the first step that I'm going
to do in my function
so I'm going to go in and I'm going to
create a new variable I'm just going to
pull it string 2 and I'm going to set it
equal to string dot split and the split
method actually requires you to put in a
parameter into the method that tells it
on what it is going to be splitting the
actual string itself so I'm using quote
quote which basically means after every
single letter in the string it's going
to split it out into an individual
element into the array now that I
haven't out into an array what I can do
is basically now I can reverse it so I
can do string 2 dot refers so now I have
my string is now reversed so it is
reversed so now I've got to figure out
what do I need to do to convert it from
an array back into an extreme and this
there is a method that's called join
that will actually convert it back into
a string so
so I'm going to use the split method I'm
going to use the same quote quote that
basically says I'm just going to convert
it all into a single stream with nothing
sung to separate them out and I now have
my string as a reverse so string two now
is an exact reverse of strength so what
I want to do is they compare these and
return them so one of the things that I
can do is I can just check to see if
string is equal to string two and if it
is I can return true else I'm going to
return false
and there I have my function that I have
written that will actually go out and
compared to see if something is a true
palindrome or not now there's some
things that I can do to actually make
this a little bit better one of the
things I can do is I can take my if
statement and take all of the scope
that's down here and I can refactor that
and I can refactor it to where it just
returns whether or not string is equal
to string two so this one line is
equivalent to what I had in my if
statement before so I make things a
little bit easier because this is going
to be either a true or false and that's
what I'm going to be returning out of my
function now there's also this thing
that I can do because in JavaScript you
can actually chain methods together so I
can actually take all these three lines
and convert them into a single line so
I'm going to change this
so I have my far and I'm going to have
far string 2 is equal to string dot
split dot now it's a race so now I'm
going to reverse and now I'm going to
join it back together so now I have
strength two in one line where I've
converted to array I don't use the built
in reverse function that's built into an
array to reverse it and then I've
converted back to a string
so now string two is an exact reverse
and I now can compare it between the two
of them to see what's going on
so what I can do is as I'm going through
and I'm actually working on my function
I can actually write it and then
completely refactor it and it while I'm
refactoring it actually explain it to
the potential employer so they can
follow my thought process so I can tell
why I put this into one line because
it's easier because I know everything
that I want to do in that string is on
one line it's easy to follow it's easy
to understand I do a single line of
return on it to compare it now another
question I might need to ask the
potential employer because technically
my function as it is written will work
there's some PUMS that this might have
on here that you need to ask as part of
your interview in your whiteboarding
exam and one of the questions that you
might need to ask would be well do I
need to worry about upper and lower case
you know because radar with a capital R
is the first letter and then a dar
technically isn't a palindrome if you
worry about case because a capital R and
a lowercase R are not equivalent so in
that case this would not would fail this
would not return as a palindrome because
of that case differential that you have
in there so you have to
ask about that well what about these
outliers what about it these exceptions
but I need to worry about and they're
like oh well I don't worry about about
case so uppercase R lowercase a dar
would return true as a palindrome just
would the lowercase R a dar would return
true well if that is the case then I
need to convert my original string to
lowercase or to uppercase it doesn't
matter so that it's consistent so what I
can do in here
and I'm just going to convert it to
lowercase and so in here I've converted
it to lowercase so now that outlier of
well what about case does that matter so
that would be a question that you might
need to ask on there another thing would
be well what do I do if what I'm passed
in is an empty string do I need to
return true or false for an empty string
so you need to ask for that so if you've
asked that question so you would need to
put in a line up here in the very
beginning that would check to test to
see if your string is a string or not
and that would be another test that you
would have would be what if somebody put
into the path sent to the function the
number 1 2 3 well that's not a string so
you're not comparing that so much.you
that would be another thing that you
would basically ask the potential
employer well what do I need to do if
this string isn't a string so somebody
passes me at any number or a boolean or
a function or something else how do i
account for that so that you need to be
able to ask these questions because just
writing a simple two line function yes
it does work will it work 100% of the
time no is what the employer paying you
to do is to write tablets will work on a
percent in time yes are you meeting that
crate
by just putting in two lines and the
answer is really no so what I've done is
I've put in the thing where I convert it
to lowercase to handle whether or not
upper lower case counts another thing
would be what if there's pronoun
pronunciation that's in there like a
space do we account for space or do we
need to remove a space that's in there
so that would be another question that
you have in there if if they tell you to
remove all punctuation like a space a
comma a period an exclamation mark a
question mark before running your test
you can do that up here just like you
converted it to lower string you can
remove all print pronunciation by using
a regex expression that takes up
annunciation marks and removes them from
the string and then you can then come on
reverse it and compare it so that would
be something else that you need to ask
the potential employer you know before
you actually you know finish up your
your test that that you have on there so
that just gives you some examples of
things that are going on on here because
basically in asking this very simple
question write a function that
determines if a string is a palindrome
what the employer like I said earlier is
basically wanting to see is how well do
you know JavaScript how do well do you
know the native data types that are in
JavaScript and the methods that are
provided with them we know that there is
a reverse that's on an array it's not
there on a string so is there a way that
I can use that even though I'm
originally starting with the string and
yes you can by knowing that you can
split a string into an array convert it
back to a string and then you can
compare them that's in there and as
you're going through and you're writing
it make sure that you communicate your
work as you're going along so that they
can understand that and I think it's
important to ask questions especially
about the outliers that about does this
case can
what if they don't pass me in this room
what do I do in that case what if the
parameter they pass in to me isn't a
string what if it's some other data type
like a number how do you want me to
handle something along that line you
know do I need to remove pronunciation
marks so I start asking questions like
that because these are real things that
you're going to get in a day-to-day
environment as a programmer and what
you're showing to that potential
employer is that when you are faced with
those on your day job you're able to
handle them successfully and that's what
they want in a potential employee I'm
going to convert over to my computer and
I'm going to give you a series of
questions that you might be asked as
part of the white board exercising
covering the topic of jQuery so once
below and I will show you these
questions here are a half-dozen
questions that you might be asked on
jQuery as part of your white board
exercising when interviewing for at the
developer position so let's go through
each of these questions question number
one what is the difference between
dollar document dot ready and window dot
onload well the main difference is that
document dot ready is the earliest
possible time that you can actually use
JavaScript or jQuery to change the Dom
in your browser the window dot onload
event actually loads after document dot
ready document got ready loads as soon
as the HTML is loaded but not when all
of the content has been loaded on the
page window dot load unload occurs later
and it mainly occurs when things like
the images that have have already been
loaded on the page itself with window
dot onload you're limited to only
being able to touch one listener to it
but you can attach as many as you want
to the dollar document not ready method
so that is a difference between document
dot ready and window dot onload number
two can you delay the execution of
dollar document dot ready and the answer
is yes you can the jQuery got hole ready
we pass in the hold to the method will
hold or release execution of jquery's
ready event the in order to make this
work
this method must be called very early in
the document so what I recommend doing
is that you put it in the head of your
HTML and you should put it as a very
first line after your script tag which
loads jQuery if you happen to call this
method after the ready event has already
fired then it will have no effect that's
why you want to load it early on so that
you can actually pause the execution of
the dollar document dot ready number
three what is the difference between
jquery's detached hide and remove
functions well let's take them one at a
time the hide function sets the element
CSS display property to none so it's
still there but you just can't see it
the remove function actually removes it
from the Dom so it's no longer there at
all
detach is kind of like removed it
removes it from the Dom but it keeps all
the stored data and events associated
with the the matched element you can
actually reinsert an item that was
detached into the Dom and the way that
you do that is that when you detach an
element you actually assign it to a
variable
then rain you want to reattach it then
you can take that variable and then just
like append it back into the body or
someplace else
so that it's now available and that's
the difference between the detached hide
and remove functions so question number
four what is the difference between
jquery's Ajax get and post functions or
methods and the main difference is the
jQuery AJAX that is kind of the umbrella
method that is that is used the dollar
get and the dollar post are subsets of
the Ajax method itself the biggest
difference between the implementation
standpoint between those two is that you
pass an object into jquery's Ajax method
in order to get all the necessary
parameters that you need to make that
call but for the dot git and the dot
post method you actually pass in
arguments and not an object and that is
the big difference between those three
the next question number five what is
the difference between dot get and dot
post the dot get method has data that's
encoded in the URL by the browser and
it's visible in the URL and it's stored
also in the web history the dot post
uses name value pairs submitted in the
body that is being sent and it's part of
the HTTP request and it cannot be seen
in the browser bar so it it has a little
bit more anonymity to it
so that's the main difference between
get and dot post and then the last
question is how can we change the
class of an element using jQuery so
jQuery actually provides three different
methods that we can use to change the
class of an element we have the add
class method we have the remove class
method and we have the toggle class
method add class as its name applies is
it will actually add a class to an
element remove class will remove the
class from the element and toggle class
what it does is is a combination of add
and remove class working together you
give it the name of a class if the
element doesn't have the class it will
add it to the element if the element
does have the class then it removes it
from the element and that is the three
different ways that you can add a class
to an element in jQuery hopefully these
these episodes have been beneficial to
you if they are feel free to leave a
comment below feel free to like this
video share it with your friends my name
again is Jennifer bland my website is
Jennifer bland com
thank you very much for watching